évidemment on ne me reproche pas le fond
de ce que c'est on n'oserait pas on
reproche la forme sauf que quoi que
passe-t-on dans TPMP je leur ai dit j'ai
un peu de culture et je sais que Victor
Hugo écrivait que la forme c'est le fond
qui remonte à la surface donc on a pas
pour une buse il y a évidemment que
c'est le fond des propos qu'on me
reproche parce que si c'est pas le cas
il faut qu'on m'explique pourquoi les
tweets antisémites racistes qu'on a
présenté à l'audience n'ont jamais été
poursuivi pourquoi est-ce que finalement
il y a des gens qui insultent la
longueur de journée qui ne sont pas
poursuivi et comme par hasard je suis le
seul à avoir été poursuivi et évidemment
uniquement dans le cadre du covid et
alors quand j'explique que je suis
désolé le temps que j'utilise la manière
dont je parle et celle dont parle comme
je parle les Français on me dit c'est
méprisant mais je comprends pas mes
prisons de quoi je comprends pas que mon
langage est méprisant mais comment ça
quand un président emmerde non vacciné
quand il dit on les aura ces connards
Castaner dit le président parle comme
les Français les manifestement moi j'ai
pas le droit de parler comme les
Français peut-être qu'il faut que je me
présente à l'élection présidentielle
pour avoir droit de parler comme les
Français qui sont que je vous dise quoi
vous y pensez moi maintenant
alors Gilles le Conseil de l'Ordre a
nagé dans ses arbres
il a été convoqué par le conseil
pour des atteintes aux principes
essentiel de la profession d'avocat on
va dire par rapport à ces tweet ou par
rapport à ses venus alors là on a dit
c'est tweet la vraie raison c'était PMP
d'accord donc le conseil de l'or dès le
début
il y a plein d'avocats qui viennent mais
lui il est malin Fabrice division c'est
vrai que quand il vient c'est ce qu'il
appelait d'ailleurs en tant que
débatteur public c'est-à-dire je donne
mon opinion de citoyen et le Conseil de
l'Ordre c'est retrouver face à ces
approximations totales en disant mais
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de lui donc la
sanction elle ne signifie rien six mois
avec sursis pour lui qui n'exerce même
plus en ce moment ça ne veut rien dire
pourquoi ils ont mis du sursis parce
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas le sanctionner
sinon c'est le bâillonné et le Bayonnais
où ici parce qu'il faut pas être dupe
derrière le Conseil de l'Ordre avocat
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière les avocats
moi je vous le dis Cyril on revient on
revient à votre conflit avec le garde
des sceaux les avocats mais je vous le
dis je vous le dis je sais pas si
Fabrice pourra le dire parce que moi je
peux le dire et lui il est le
protagoniste donc je le dis moi-même
voilà et vous si je dis des bêtises vous
m'arrêtez comme une anecdote avant-hier
avant-hier je suis comme d'appel de
magistrats que je connais et de
confrères qui m'ont dit écoute il ferait
peut-être que tu tiennes un peu éloigné
de Cyril
à un moment donc c'est bien
et en fait j'ai demandé pourquoi et j'ai
pas tout compris moi je comprends rien
ces histoires on me dit parce que bon
voilà il marque Mouli qui s'est retrouvé
poursuivi parce qu'ils ont TPMP voilà
toi tu t'es retrouvé pour sucre dans
TPMP et bon Cyril et le garde des sceaux
c'est pas un secret que manifestement il
y a un bisbille j'ai été super étonné
qu'on me dit ça j'ai moi je voilà et en
fait je je prévois on s'entend très bien
avec plein de personnes du gouvernement
après
bien avec Gérald Darmanin avec
Gabriela
mais heureusement on s'entend avec tout
le gouvernement et même avec tous les
gens moi je m'entends très bien avec mes
mec plein de gens de LSI la Raquelle est
une amie Alexis aussi de partout moi de
tout moi j'ai des amis partout voilà je
vous le dis
avant après juste Éric Dupont-Moretti on
va pas revenir là-dessus il a fait un
coup d'éclat dans cet avoue en parlant
de moi voilà après je lui ai demandé je
te dis je lui écris avant-hier je lui ai
dit bah viens on va voilà il faut qu'on
se voit il faut que tu viennes pour j'ai
pas de réponse après voilà peut-être
qu'il me répondra un jour mais pour
l'instant il va pas répondre mais en
tout cas je vous dire ça a pas l'air de
déranger les autres membres du
gouvernement qui viennent ici et qui
continuent à avoir les donc voilà donc
voilà lui ce qu'on lui reproche aussi
regardez ça entre guillemets c'est
d'être un peu le ministre des avocats
d'accord on lui reproche ça il était en
vocal lui-même on lui reproche ça contre
les magistrats et qui a sanctionné
Fabrice division ce sont des avocats
donc Cyril on a franchement Fabrice le
disait aussi tout le monde dit en ce
moment qu'il y a chez lui une fixation
et il fait tout ce qu'il peut pour
entraver la liberté d'expression dans
l'émission moi moi je prends des risques
en disant surtout c'est qu'on a un vrai
problème on a un recul des marges de la
liberté d'expression dans ce pays et ça
va devenir inquiétant il faut être très
clair c'est tout en fait que l'avocat et
les polémiste par nature je veux dire
que aujourd'hui tout à l'heure tu as
posé la question effectivement la
ministre est-ce que je suis complotiste
mais moi j'aurais aimé qu'on réponde à
cette question parce que quand je suis
venu ici et chacun le sait je suis chef
du groupe un débat sur interroger
exactement effectivement toujours été
l'homme de la mesure sur poser des
questions et de la démesure sur la forme
mais j'ai toujours été celui qui a
interrogé les choses et je vais te dire
et Fabrice je le redis maintenant tu
avais raison sur des choses voilà tu
nous avais dit à l'époque tu avais voilà
tu avais des trucs qu'on avait vérifié
d'autres pas mais tu es venu pour
discuter tu as eu des débats tu t'es
voilà tu t'es faillite avec Géraldine
avec Mathieu avec tout le monde il y a
eu un débat tu es pas venu ici pour
faire un exposé comment il faut penser
mais ça c'est intéressant tu sais que en
manif pour la petite histoire quand les
gens mettent le lycée je leur disait
mais vous êtes dingue si vous demandez
pourquoi on est dans la merde c'est
parce qu'il y a un mec que vous
connaissez pas qui monte sur un podium
et vous l'applaudissez vous êtes fous je
veux dire c'est il faut pas faire ça il
faut surtout pas faire ça déjà moi j'ai
toujours été l'homme de la raison et
c'est ce que j'expliquais à l'ordre en
disant écoutez moi j'ai quand même un
problème dans cette affaire c'est qu'à
un moment donné nous étions dans une
polémique et il fallait effectivement
que les opinions s'expriment et il y a
des avocats qui ont dit qu'il fallait
faire leur maison non vaccinés pour
qu'il paye leur soin de réanimation
est-ce que c'est forcément beaucoup
moins grave lorsque un avocat explique
dans un dans un journal que on est
comparable les non-vacs à des personnes
qui transmettent volontaire dans le VIH
est-ce que c'est forcément un propos
qu'on peut qualifier de modérer donc si
vous voulez je suis pas complètement
stupide la vérité dans cette crise c'est
qu'il y a une opinion autorisée et une
opinion interdite j'ai incarné l'opinion
interdite c'est tout
bon
weekend avec Béatrice et Delphine je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'avocats qui
vont vouloir se réconcilier avec toi
vont peut-être pas aller au barreau mais
ils auront le baron
effectivement je pense que ce qui pose
problème c'est le fond des des pensées
de Fabrice division et quand on lit dans
la presse les motifs de la sanction ils
sont complètement lunaire on parle de
propos grossis vulgaire n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi les arguments en
fait s'ils veulent les arguments sont
nuls s'ils veulent interdire cette
pensée qui est différente effectivement
de la leur sur les vaccins qui le disent
directement plutôt que d'infliger des
sanctions qui sont ridicules et
complètement
disparuzzi et je vais vous dire c'est
toujours comme ça faut arrêter les mecs
Fabrice des vidéos c'est devenu une star
on va pas se raconter l'histoire et
voilà et je vous dis il y a une énorme
jalousie autour de lui de de vos frères
et moi je te dis ctpmp oui bien sûr mais
c'est tout voilà tu as été partout on
parlait que toi il y a Booba qui est
trop tweet tu es devenu une star je te
dis la vérité et il y a de la jalousie
c'est comme ça dans tous les métiers
sache que c'est comme ça en médecine
aussi dès que tu es un médecin qui
devient un peu star et ben ils essaient
de le casser quand il y a c'est partout
comme ça et aujourd'hui ce qui dérange
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils disent pourquoi
c'est lui et pourquoi c'est pas nous
sache-le parce que c'est c'est comme si
je vais te dire moi c'est comme tous les
journalistes et tous les chroniqueurs et
tous les mecs qui disent oui TPMP ou
TPMP quand je les appelle c'est les
premiers à venir ici hein ils sont tous
contents et après ils me disent [ __ ]
c'est dingue je suis on va jamais autant
parlé d'une télé bah c'est pareil donc
voilà tu es d'accord avec moi alors je
vais te dire moi ça fait trois semaines
que pour le coup je te défends sur les
réseaux je veux dire où je ne sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs tout le monde pense
que on doit avoir des actions communes
ou je sais pas quoi mais non appelle-moi
maintenant c'est un truc et je le dis
jeudi Fabrice c'est un ami comme je l'ai
et je le dis c'est vraiment devenir un
pote et Fabrice on n'est pas d'accord
sur des trucs on est d'accord sur des
trucs et moi mais c'est important de pas
être d'accord bien sûr c'est ce que vous
avez dit en fin d'année pour le coup
c'est important pas d'accord moi je te
fous beaucoup de respect pour chacun et
si vous voulez moi cette décision elle
elle impacte pas si José je dirais un
truc mais il a effectivement bref bon et
non non
c'est pas ce que je veux dire c'est que
je vais quand même relever appel à la
demande de mon associé d'une de mes
associés qui a plaidé le dossier avec le
collège de défense et qui dit on peut
pas accepter ça on peut pas l'accepter
pour nos clients ça amène Bouchard
magnifique associé qui dit on peut pas
l'accepter on peut pas accepter ça
pendant le client on peut pas accepter
ça pour nous pour la profession pour les
jeunes qui rentrent dedans il faut un
moment donné qu'on se bat pour les
principes moi je veux dire que je
prenais les risques en faisant appel il
est possible que la sanction soit
aggravée en appel et je m'en fous j'irai
d'un cours européenne des droits de
l'homme jusqu'au bout parce qu'à un
moment donné je rappelle quand même une
chose qui est fondamentale c'est que le
journaliste et l'avocat sont considérés
comme les chiens de garde de la
démocratie qui soit des chiens ça j'ai
compris de garde c'est un peu plus
compliqué aujourd'hui alors moi je
voudrais pour finir là-dessus je dis que
je les redis je l'ai dit à l'instant
Fabrice c'est un pote voilà je vous dis
on est d'accord sur des trucs on n'est
pas d'accord sur les autres mais ce que
je sais c'est que Fabrice il est droit
dans ses bottes et Fabrice dès j'ai
besoin de lui il a toujours été là et ça
il est venu
le prévenir 365 points même quand il y a
pas d'émission il sera là sur le plateau
ah mais je le dis rien à [ __ ]
voilà
on pense qu'il veut on est d'accord avec
on n'est pas d'accord avec lui mais je
peux vous dire que c'est un gars tu
l'appelles à n'importe quelle heure tu
demandes un truc qu'il est toujours là
pour toi essayer de venir un pote et je
le dis et j'ai pas peur de dire que
Fabrice c'est un pote et Fabrice tu
seras toujours le bienvenu ici et je
vais te dire tu crées des jalousies de
c'est comme ça t'inquiète pas c'est les
mecs c'est tous des ils aiment ils
aiment tout le monde aime la lumière que
si tu as je pense un truc là c'est que
2022 a été vraiment l'année de la
scission elle se passe vaccinale avec
toutes ces polémiques il importe au plus
haut point que de ils ont 3 soit
vraiment l'année de la reconstruction
ensemble exactement impérativement que
c'est pour ça que je t'avais dit par SMS
moi je me suis mis à disposition ça me
demande beaucoup de temps une journée
par semaine où je reçois les gens les
abîmés de la vie ou effectivement on
essaye de régler les problèmes
gratuitement on essaie de les écouter tu
as raison et je fais pas de distinction
entre les vases les antivaces ça ça
existe pas en fait on essaie vraiment de
remettre à notre mesure un peu
d'humanité dans une société qu'on a
cruellement manqué la justice est saisie
elle répondra des responsables les uns
et les autres répondront de la
responsabilité mais aujourd'hui on
pourra pas faire société si on si on est
si on entame pas un chemin de
réconciliation c'est tout non mais je
suis d'accord avec toi et je vais te
dire un truc aujourd'hui moi je vois
aussi là les gars là qui ici on est on
est pour le dialogue c'est ce que je
vois oui on est en brouille avec le
garde des sous il y a pas d'un coup dans
aucune embrouille avec le garde des
sceaux le garde des sceaux il vient
quand il veut Eric Dupond-Moretti ici au
contraire nous on est pour le dialogue
voilà il y a pas d'embrouille entre lui
entre moi on s'en fout de ça on n'est
pas là pour perdre du temps à
s'embrouiller il faut faire avancer les
choses et tu as raison aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il faut qu'on regarde tous vers
la même direction quand je vois aussi
des éditorialistes sans talent comme
Sophia Aram qui ferait mieux de
s'occuper des histoires de sa mère qui a
arnaqué des milliers de gens voilà les
centaines de gens et que là qu'il avait
été condamné d'ailleurs condamné Samir
catastrophique ce qu'elle a fait j'ai vu
alors bah là on juge pas sa mère elle
fait voilà mais bon freineux de
s'occuper de compagnie plutôt de
s'occuper de nous à parler de nous toute
la journée et puis fermer de s'occuper
d'avoir du talent je crois qu'elle fait
des tweets des trucs et allons dans la
même direction mais c'est vrai Sofia
Aram ou truc allons tous dans la même
direction je vous dis on a connu une
année 2022 difficile 2023 va être
compliqué pour beaucoup de gens il vaut
mieux aller tous dans la direction au
bord du chemin exactement voilà c'est ça
moi mon combat en fait il est exactement
celui-là c'est d'essayer de le laisser
personne dans du matin parler de star je
sais pas si je suis une star c'est pas
ça en tout cas moi j'ai une notoriété il
faut l'utiliser aujourd'hui pour
permettre de reconstruire ensemble et
pour permettre véritablement d'arrêter
les discriminations et d'arrêter et de
rebâtir ensemble il y a des abîmés de la
vie il y a des gens qui ont plus besoin
de se payer des chauffages on verra les
restrictions ensuite là dans un premier
temps ce qu'il faut c'est aider chacun
en fait exactement et j'aimerais bien
savoir ce qu'ils font les bobos de
France Inter là comme Sofia Aram
Guillaume Meury c'est tout ça là tous
les les bobos la France Inter qui sont
toute la journée en train de de boire
des cafés au Café de Flore là où je sais
où hein cette bande non mais c'est vrai
ah j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'il faut
pour les gens pour moi avec mes impôts
parce que c'est nous qui les payons je
vous le dis cette demande d'abruti de
France je vous le dis qui nous mettent
de la gueule toute la journée qui font
rien pour les autres qui pensent qu'à
leur petite gueule à aller prendre aller
boire des verres en Stan Smith je peux
vous dire j'espère les croiser un jour
parce que quand on arrive devant eux je
vous le dis et c'est tout ils sont tout
mignons et tout gentils non non j'ai
jamais dit ça c'est pas vraiment ce que
j'ai dit tu avais énormément de talent
tu es le meilleur donc moi je vais vous
dire quand on porte ses couilles on les
porte jusqu'au bout c'est pas seulement
sur les réseaux sociaux ou derrière le
micro donc voilà qui vient de me le dire
ici ou qui vient de me le dire demain
merci ça va bien mon compte